levitt joins us now good morning to you
joseph gordon-levitt good to be here i
remember travis very well i i thought he
had a lot of swagger he was very
charismatic i i like the mantra number
one was always be hustling that's the
core value number one yes and at the
time when it broke out people were like
wow and in awe of him and the court of
public opinion has not turned out to be
the case i was wondering did you have an
opinion of him before you played him and
how you prepared playing i didn't really
know who he was personally of course
knew about uber and yeah realized that
it had all of a sudden become everywhere
so fast and you know it really it was
the fastest growing startup in history
and uh i i got to know a lot of people
that work closely with him and a lot of
people were saying the same things you
just said about how inspiring he was how
energetic he was yes but he also i think
made some decisions that were really
questionable decisions some uh ethically
questionable behavior inside the company
and uh this show doesn't shy away from
either side of him yeah so what did what
did you want the story to be about him
how did you want to portray him so you
know i'm not a journalist but like you
are i'm an actor so it's my job not to
just talk about what happened we were
relying on the new york times journalism
for what happened my job is to find out
how it felt who's the guy as a human
being so that's again why i wanted to go
beyond the
what was said about him in the press and
and talk to the people that that were
actually closest what'd you find out
yeah well
exactly what you said which is that a
lot of the kind of demonization that you
find is maybe a little over simplified
and i think you can judge a person's
actions without judging their personhood
and
i think it's really important that we
hold him accountable and hold his
company accountable for the laws they
broke and the negative impact they had
on all sorts of people's lives but i
think it's also not that useful to just
reduce somebody to a villain when
they're a whole human being and and so i
wanted to show that whole human yeah
right away you get you take
viewers back home with travis you see
his family meet his brother his parents
uh you say this is bigger than uber
that's a big takeaway explain that
i'd that was one of the biggest reasons
for me that i was inspired to do this
show was because i think there is
something about it that's that's bigger
than travis and bigger than uber which
is when a company is prioritizing
profits over everything and and doesn't
mind who they have to step on or
negatively impact in order to produce
those profits you're going to keep
getting these companies doing harm we
keep asking like how do we fix facebook
how do we fix this that until they have
different incentives where they can care
about more than you know shareholder
value
they're not going to fix any of those
problems because it's it's not good
business yeah speaking of incentives one
of the incentives to watching this
series is the all-star cast i mean kyle
chandler uma thurman yourself amongst
others what is it like being on the set
with that type of talent does it raise
your level of game when you're acting
okay so you mentioned uma thurman of
course who plays ariana huffington and
nails it to the wall
she is so good
but i mean okay so i was i was i think
14 when pulp fiction came out that movie
is a very you know it's a fixture in my
appreciation of of art and and
she's just such a glowing presence and
and her performance in this is so
stellar i was just in a state of
euphoria really against her yeah wow
that's a good way listen you nailed
travis too oh thank you yeah we got to
see many sides of travis and we can't
underestimate what uber has accomplished
here i think do you have an uber account
i do yeah
because the pandemic but they bought
postmates yeah so now you know yes i i
have to admit and and i and i feel a
little bit bad every time i order from
post mates dude
well i i think there's probably some
real questions about how they treat
restaurants and how restaurants are able
to stay in business with these kinds of
businesses so you made a really big
point earlier about how companies behave
and why they behave the way they do and
particularly startups they take money
from investors they got to make good on
that money and they they hurt some
people in the process do you think a
show like this a series like this is
going to help people rethink that system
i think that we as a whole culture have
some big changes that we have to make in
our minds about what success is and what
a good company is like really big
changes or we're just gonna drive off a
cliff and whether you're talking about
whatever issue you care about whether
it's the environment or justice or
health
until businesses are responsible for
more than profits we're just gonna keep
having these huge problems people are
asking these questions but can i just
talk about you from back in the day
because i used to watch you in a third
rock from the sun but you've been doing
this for a while it's true yeah so how
old were you when you started i was six
years old and you loved it
you knew i loved it there's a story my
mom tells i i only kind of remember the
first job i ever did it was a commercial
we were in uncomfortable clothes there
was fake rain she thought he's never
gonna want to do this again we walked
out of the soundstage after they said
rap and i was like it's night time
i was so you had no idea yeah i had been
so into it i didn't even realize that
night had fallen i i've just always
loved getting to be on a team working
with a crew and telling stories it's my
favorite thing we love you man you're
one of the best in the business thank
you yeah that's really cool you know
what's cool about him he says dancing
with his little boys every day gives him
pure glory i just love somebody like
that they're going to love you voices
you know your next project yeah i can't
wait for them to see pinocchio it's
really true i got to play jiminy cricket
we'll talk about that thank you and
you're giving nate a run for his money
in the dap ralph look at that soon
you'll win today
superman look good
he's in super pumped the battle for uber
premieres this sunday on showtime
division of paramount